[Music]
automated piece of [ __ ]
it's the evil siri the zoom
being series i actually asked google the
other day
if she was male or female and she said
she has no gender
then i asked if she loved me and she
said yes which is weird
so yeah they're pretty fun to talk to
you yeah she loves you for having bought
her as a product
i take care of her okay i provide her
with power and electricity that i pay
for you know i'm her daddy
and her lover siri's got that will to
power
all right today i mean we're gonna we're
shooting the [ __ ] a little bit here
yeah listeners because we've done some
heavy
heavy recent episodes real deep dives
into a particular theorist and we're
gonna do
i think heidegger next and i've i've
been listening
back to our our old uh or some of our
old episodes and we always say we're
just gonna
do this philosopher
it's weird that discussing a theorist is
is uh just the active
verb to do
yeah it's it's kind of like a not the
deep dive approach but the sort of broad
reading approach i guess i don't know
others do
deeper dives on specific topics too so
that's interesting
but this might also be like a male
centric perspective but
to me a deep dive into someone sounds
just as sexual as like we're going to do
them if you know what i mean
hetero heterosexual just male
perspective
from the perspective of like media it
does seem like when people talk about
like something episodic they'll usually
say oh yeah we're going to be doing that
next or
you might say like we're going to cover
that person also but
but yeah we do tend to use the do cover
sounds a lot more maternal
maybe but it's true like i like i don't
think i'm sure maybe some of us have
even said that without noticing right
like we'll cover
uh heidegger next or something i don't
know
yeah well duluth did say that it like a
it's one big ass [ __ ] anyway there you
go
he does literally do philosophers or he
thinks he does
and then they give anal birth to some
kind of
new concept i think if anyone has a
claim to doing other philosophers it's
derrida andaluz africa they always point
out how
sexual all our language is anyway like
concept and conception
childbirth and having an idea eros
semiotics semen dissemination i mean in
some ways there's a long
history to this if you think back to the
symposium which is basically like hey
you know me and the boys we're gonna get
together we're gonna have some wine
we're gonna talk about philosophies and
we're all gonna [ __ ] at the end of it
right
so so before anyone turns this episode
off
the the title is fak news
um and we've been talking about a lot of
news lately between
us on our on our multiple platforms
on our our writing our streaming
and this i think we can start by talking
about the news because there's some out
there but
just in case you want to turn this off
because you're tired of the news
i think most of this episode is going to
be dedicated to an analysis of the term
news from of course a theory perspective
so rather than doing a deep
dive we are doing a topical episode on
what is the news if we're gonna theorize
about it
so let's do news boys well i mean
there's obviously a lot going on we did
we did our
live stream and at that time when we did
our live stream i don't think we really
like knew the outcome so i guess
and maybe we don't we still don't know
the outcome and
it seems to be the thing that's
dominating news at least american news
that and i guess like
rises in covid but i mean it seems like
joe biden won
so i don't know i'll just mention that
to get it out of the way hopefully that
remains true
well we got some canadian news too that
eric was ranting about in the discord
yeah yeah eric why don't you explain
that to us
start with uh yeah oh well first of all
uh
remembrance day is coming up is it is it
coming up
no it was yesterday it was yesterday man
is that an american holiday also or
something else they have like vet is it
veterans day there
and they don't wear poppies the way we
do oh so
okay in canada remembrance day has
already passed and there's an incident
with whole foods
where whole foods oh that's right yeah
they they banned their
um they banned their employees from
wearing poppies at work
and it caused a big stink in canadian
politics
especially conservative politics yeah
but even
you heard a response from the uh the new
democrats there's a response from
the conservatives and liberals seem to
keep kind of quiet about it
but basically of whole foods who banned
their employees
earlier from wearing any black lives
matter
paraphernalia at work which went
virtually unnoticed
and then this time around when they
banned the poppies the
the news went ballistic and they're
saying they're
saying oh everyone should be able to
wear a poppy at work and they just
this was on the basis of um of like
just uniforms right and for our like
non-canadian listeners
the poppy is obviously a symbol of like
remembering the sacrifice that the
troops
uh have given for like world war one and
world war ii
and uh it's just a little flower that
pins to like your shirt it's like a
little
it's a tiny little red flower what
probably like two inches in diameter or
something like that i bought one
actually two days ago at the el sabia
yeah
just now in flanders fields where
poppies grow
something
it's a world war one poem right and the
british also wear a poppy although their
poppy is different
listen to leonard cohen recite that poem
and it was genuinely [ __ ] pretty
chilling
you know what i mean yeah in canadian
culture it kind of means
when you wear a poppy it means that
you're remembering the people who
sacrificed themselves for the country
but there's a little bit of um
contestation over the narrative of
whether or not you're
supporting the troops and the sort of
like military apparatus or whether it's
a sort of
never again type thing where we say
like they died in these senseless wars
for the
the masters of war as the bob dylan song
goes and that we should be holding
the the ruling class accountable for
these these senseless wars they started
so
so some people have a sort of patriotic
interpretation of it and some people
have a kind of like
never again interpretation but it
prompted
ford to write a piece of legislation
saying that
businesses could not ban their employees
from wearing poppies which is great
thanks for that doug ford
spa whole foods by the way is owned by
jeff bezos the
richest man in the world and
he this is the only intervention into
working conditions he's made besides the
back in march when he wrote legislation
saying you
that you could take a week or two off
work unpaid
if you felt sick and this is the second
piece of sort of worker legislation
and what really pissed me off is also
the ndp responses like andrea horwath
the the leader of the
the new democrats which is our sort of
socialist
party is uh they came out she came out
and said
uh like ford should be allowing
workers to wear whatever they like at
work kind of thing
like she didn't make it about free
expression
in the workplace just like people should
be able to choose whether or not to wear
a poppy
so she missed the opportunity to make a
free expression argument
she missed the opportunity to condemn
betso's
and his shitty treatment that's well
documented of his workers who he's
become rich off of and even richer since
the pandemic started
it's a whole cluster [ __ ] of just stupid
stupid political
[ __ ] and i i just i was surprised though
i mean like the ndp coalition in
ontario basically consists of ultra woke
uh intellectuals artists um
various minority groups but then like
this is the key one like blue collar
workers right uh particularly
in heavy industry uh who tend to be
unionized and
that last group is probably going to be
pretty militantly opposed to any efforts
to
contradict the message of the poppy as
they understand it yeah i mean
i gotta say i got no problem with this
like in the sense of like
i agree like ford should do more but
like just as an isolated act i feel like
i have no problem with him doing that
because i just hate the idea that that
um
private corporations are telling their
employees that what they can and can't
wear so like just
just even if it makes the smallest
contribution to a road the power of
employers to do that i'm for it
and ford if our non-american listeners
uh remember our crack smoking mayor
was his brother was his brother who was
dead so now his other brother got
elected by
i don't know who can i believe not just
the mayor of toronto but the premier of
ontario yeah people thought that he was
going to be like the trump of the north
and i got to tell you it really didn't
turn out that way like i don't agree
with a lot of his policies but i think
he's been broadly
competent and he has even done some he
has like pushed some policies that i
actually strongly
agree with specifically related to
transit i won't bore you with the
details but like yeah he has
a transit plan for toronto that i really
agree with and overall i thought his
like response to covet has been like i
don't know as good as any other typical
politician like i don't think
like it didn't seem like at the very
least i can say that
it didn't feel worse and i also like the
fact that he
was working with the other premiers
working with the federal government even
though they're of different parties and
was just saying yeah and he even praised
them he was like justin trudeau did an
amazing job
christopher freeland didn't so like i
just liked those things but like do i
agree with him i mean he's a
conservative so like obviously i'm not
foremost
he is a thumb in a suit yeah that's
that's a lot of turd polishing you're
doing there and i'm not really
for it at all because he makes this
intervention into the workplace not to
protect workers from shitty working
conditions
yeah but to say workers you can wear a
poppy
you're not allowed to be uh told not to
i only that's like i'm gonna make an
intervention into the workplace and
that's the angle i'm going yeah sure
[ __ ] poppies once a year
i was only saying that in the context of
like people thinking he was going to be
like a trump of the north
right like obviously i agree that like
he's a typical but he just turned out to
be a typical conservative a typical
canadian conservative he did not seem
he did not turn out to be like some
weird populist trump at all but his
his his guarantee to be able to wear
these poppies though is
he's framing it as a war on christmas
thing like you have to write christmas
on your starbucks cup
well he took a page out of trump's book
recently i mean he
just uh he just fast-tracked uh he just
he just uh
eliminated environmental um assessments
for building and fast-track building
projects so for instance in in near
toronto they're trying to build a
a fact not a factory a warehouse in a
wetland
and the uh environmental protection
groups
were saying no and now he's passed a
bill to say okay
you guys have no more power we can
fast-track these things so he's taking
pages out of trump's book like they are
flirting with trumpism but now that he's
out of office
well i mean that's not that's like
that's a typical that's like a typical
conservative
playbook thing to like to like uh cut
regular like i don't i don't see that as
a uniquely like
i don't see that as like oh this is a
page out of trump at all that's just
like
conservatives cutting regulation to
stimulate industry that's just what they
always do
yeah it's pretty much devastated the epa
is um the approach is actually taken to
homelessness in toronto and some of the
other big metropolitan areas because
a lot of people have been uh thrown out
of their apartments in their homes
because of covid and they've been
shacking up in different parks usually
intense right uh which is
pretty worrying when you think that it's
november and so far the weather hasn't
quite broken but it's going too soon
right
and the city has been trying to get rid
of these people
and a lot of advocates for uh the
homeless have said well where are they
supposed to go
right you know they've gone to the only
place they can uh and there's not enough
room in shelters and it's especially
difficult with covid
going on right now since you don't want
cram people into one place and the
government has
absolutely no sympathy for that at least
thus far i do agree with victor
though i don't think that even that is
really all that different than what
you'd see from a typical conservative uh
in a canadian mole
i don't know there's there's nothing
there's nothing exceptionally trumpist
about doug ford he's just a conservative
who i disagree with but
did did kathleen win the previous
premiere
put those environmental protections in
place
did she do that so if she didn't then
that means they were around during the
harper era too
and he didn't guys guys we're way too in
the weeds here
we have an international audience that's
all speculation
oh you're getting i'm deep connected i'm
just saying i'm just saying like that is
deep canadian politics
i i just think like the the trying to
link him like just to be
like to join the club of like you know
authoritarianism and be like ooh like
doug ford is like our version like no
that's feeble like he's nothing like
them
he's just a conservative i see trump
deconstructing regulations
and now i see four deconstructing
regulations
i see a similarity there because
environmental regulations are a
provincial prerogative in canada
they are not a federal prerogative like
they are in the states which is why we
do not have big strong environmental
groups up here
and [ __ ] you if you don't see that
because i'm right and you're wrong i
mean we're just we're
we're just disagreeing about what to
label the thing i think we all agree
that what he's doing
on this thing is bad i agree with that
it's more just a question of um
i don't know marketing how like the left
wants to like bring i don't know like i
think there's a temptation on the left
to want to like brand things as being
like trumpism or like connected to this
like global
like authoritarian like like like wave
and i just don't see that at all i don't
really see that in canada much it's just
he's just being a shitty conservative
and he's deregulating stuff
yeah i'd say the same thing like i would
never have voted for andrew scheer uh
last election right was he trump north
no he was a pretty conventional cpc
uh leader who agitated some moderate
social conservative policies
and some pretty tight uh fiscal
conservative party pills is shaking his
head he doesn't want us to i'm shaking
my head because
who the [ __ ] knows what cpc is you think
germans know what cpc is
conservative party of canada thank you
yeah i think
we can all agree that mad max bernier
was the real guy
flirting with trump's style oh yeah i'm
not going to resoundingly smack down in
canada
because we are so diverse and well we're
like
we're like american politics but with
the extreme ends chopped off
okay listen eric you will not understand
the satisfaction i got when the people's
party of canada was resoundingly
rejected by the people
and bernier even lost his own writing
you know there was a certain
satisfaction that i got from that that i
wouldn't necessarily call erotic but it
wasn't not erotic i mean there was a
little chub involved in that i would say
that my feelings of watching trump lose
and squirm is maybe borderline erotic
that feels real yeah yeah oh definitely
right uh i mean like uh there was this
jim carrey sketch where he was sitting
there and he's playing biden and he was
like
we sit there and we like we feel like
we're above this and
the problem with this is that there has
to be a winner and uh
yeah that was good i was like oh
oh say it again satisfying very very
satisfying
maybe we should just talk about that a
little bit and what's happening with
i mean the media in general and and i
mean trump doing exactly what people
sort of feared he was doing i mean
bernie sanders talked about this
that that like the election would the
results would be ambiguous because of
male in voting and then
trump would declare victory right like i
think the night that night
like in the mid like probably like i
think it was like a 2 a.m in the morning
he was like he was like as far as i'm
concerned we did win and he's like we're
gonna go to the
supreme court and it's like rigged he
says all kinds of con
um contradictory [ __ ] and like i got to
say today
i'm saying like all the votes for
republicans are legal and
the votes cast for democrats where they
voted for
republicans down ballot the down ballot
should count just not the one on top of
that
i know it doesn't make any sense and i
did see a stat today that something like
40 percent or no it was 60
of people who voted for trump think the
results are illegitimate
right now which is oh yeah well that's
insane
well did you see his twitter today
i did he was lashing out at the
department of justice calling them all
traders
and watching out at fox news he was
lashing out at fox news which i think
is a key to getting where he's going
after he gets kicked out
he's setting himself up for a job at
this other
news max or something like that newsmax
and there's also one america network or
something like one
yeah he's also he's also flirting with
creating what they're provisionally
calling trump tv
afterwards which i actually think would
probably be one of his more successful
business ventures because if he set up
anyway
he probably would go yeah that would
make money he could pay off all his
debts his hundreds of millions of
dollars in debt
he'll probably buy one of them and then
just turn it into trump tv
politically he'll be somewhere between
like rush limbaugh and
alex jones i think that's like something
where no but alice jones is definitely
smarter than trump
like oh and so is rush limbaugh yeah so
is russ limbaugh yeah they peddle
[ __ ] but they knowingly pedal
[ __ ] well
the thing here's actually the
interesting thing i think that like
makes trump
actually probably pretty weak on tv as a
tv personality with
is because he doesn't actually have
opinions like yeah i don't actually
think trump has like strong views
about anything that is not connected to
feeling narcissistically satisfied
so like unless he can spin it to be like
something about how like look what i did
look what uh
like i don't think he has opinions about
about anything whereas like rush
limbaugh and these other people
actually have opinions that are like
non-narcissistically
grounded or something like that that's a
really good point yeah i mean
if you ever see trump talk about policy
where he's not attacking someone else
right
he's pretty boring and low low energy
dare i say right it's like
yeah yeah i mean like you know we're not
going to allow socialism in this country
it's going to be the greatest tax plan
ever
uh and the answer he gives is like it's
going to be better it's going to be the
best he's like we're going to like
repeal and replace obamacare with
something much better it's going to be
beautiful it's going to be like a
beautiful dance like
but but just go to the theme i i will
say like one of the interesting things
about this
like election has been how polarized the
media reaction has been because there's
literally
like everyone on the spectrum right
there's like far-right news sites that
are basically like a coup
is taking place where the democrats are
trying to take over the country we need
to rise up and stop it
so like somewhere around the squishy
middle with like the established
networks msnbc fox
where people are variably happy about it
but more or less willing to accept the
consensus
to like far-left media that are
basically saying exactly what the
far-right media is saying
there's a coup taking place but on the
other side right republicans are trying
to co-opt things
and they're going to destroy the well
what's interesting about like the way
these messages get
just like distributed through online
social media actually
before we were taping we were talking
about daniel addison there's someone who
we both follow on twitter who's kind of
got these like
right-wing uh like like anti-liberal
views and
he was talking about how somebody i
forget i forget who it was that tweeted
um like um this this claim that all
these i noticed all these right-wing
commentators retweeting it and being
like look
at this like typical like new york times
liberal and it was like
saying something like i think his name
is ruse his last name is roos i don't
know if you saw this matt like
he was saying yeah just for
conservatives out there it's possible
for you to be saying factually true
things
yet they are part of a misinformation
campaign and all these
and all these conservatives were like
retweeting it being like but all these
things are true like totally missing the
point i don't know at least
i didn't get it that was actually what
uh me and daniel addison i think is the
name we're talking about
because like like you know the things
can be like so it's true for example
that uh i don't know bill barr is
opening an investigation into voter
fraud
and then it's true that maybe like a
couple of dead people voted
and it's true that like there's some
debate about whether or not the law in
pennsylvania to like accept
uh ballots that come in after the
election polls close
but all those things combined even
though like when you add them all up
add up to almost nothing and like at
most i don't know like a few thousand
poll
uh ballots would be thrown out but like
all those things add up to give
people a sense like there's all this
voter fraud going on so it's like
factually true things that contribute
and i don't know why conserve like some
conservative
commentators i've been watching are
seeing that that observation as being
like
a slam dunk like example of i don't know
like the new york times elite
who are like i don't know i don't i
didn't get it and i didn't get a
satisfying answer
i think that's a really good like a
point right and this is something that
trump has been really gifted at when it
comes to
peddling um all this kind of [ __ ] to
conservative media because
there's usually at least a tangential
grain of truth in everything that he
says
uh but he'll always couch it in such a
way that
it'll produce certain results and
certain kinds of affect in a supporters
without him ever having to be committed
to
epistemic consequences um or any
epistemic connotations to his statements
like he'll say things which is exactly
what's going on right now with rudy
giuliani like
well people are saying uh that throw out
is going on or people have seen
fraud going on or people are claiming
fraud is going on
and all that might be true right uh it
doesn't mean anything has actually
happened
but the statement that people are
claiming it's true
is true right and because you kind of
create so much distance between yourself
and what's actually going on in the
world in a general way
uh you can always deny any kind of
accountability for what it is that
you're talking about
while generating the kind of kind of
responses that you want right
yeah absolutely i mean i think i wanted
to say uh there's a
term i learned for like a couple weeks
ago actually i was listening to a
podcast this marketer talks about how
like
you know one of the tools in the tool
belt of marketing
like they name different kinds of
campaigns and then there's one that they
call fudd
which is fear uncertainty doubt right
it's like it's advertising and messaging
that
is meant to instill as much fear as much
uncertainty and as much doubt
as possible and i mean i think that this
this has been a perfect example of that
in some ways and i wonder i don't know
i think that there's like psycholog
there's something like there's
interesting psychological mechanisms and
i wonder if we could connect it like
what kinds of theories we could connect
it to like if it fits in with like
lacanian psychoanalysis or other things
just
you know it does seem like there's a
there's a there's a kind of i don't know
if i want to call it a vulnerability or
a mechanism inside in the human psyche
that is
tempted by things up that are that
instill a sense of fear uncertainty
doubt versus like nuance
and like like care and i don't know
um no but my turn my turn yeah go ahead
we are 23 minutes in we've covered
canadian news our opinions on canadian
news
we've covered american news so we can
keep talking about that um
the interruption the interruption is
just to
let's move to or at least offer a few
frames for this because i think what you
what you're just trying to move to well
you just offered
uh fear uncertainty doubt um
my question like to riff off that or to
advance that thesis would be
is that the function of news
specifically a certain kind of news
and the questions that i want to get to
in the next 40 minutes or so
is very specifically how does everyone
having access to so much news and so
many different news sources at the same
time
how does that change what we thought of
as something like
journalistic or journalistic integrity
those kinds of questions so if you can
if you're going to provide examples
fine but instead of just dealing back
and forth throwing examples at each
other
if you can try to frame uh maybe the
psychological effective news what you
think the purpose is
i mean we could go into ideology we
could go into spectacle so i'm gonna let
it go
where it may but i would like to keep
this a little bit to
let's reflect on what the news in
general does and how it functions
well yeah i mean i think uh i think that
like there is a bias
in the news towards sensationalism which
is i think connected to
fear uncertainty doubt fud because
like it that is for whatever reason
that's the thing that is more most
tempting and
you know i think we could even connect
it to um
ideology like in the al-sazarian sense
because like if i recall correctly it's
something like you know ideology for him
is you know a representation of reality
at the level of ideas that
you know um mystifies or or conceals
much of that reality by presenting
partial truths as if they're whole
truths
right and i think that's a another
another good way of describing what like
fudd is doing and i think in general the
media the news what's their incentive
right their incentive is to get viewers
and what are the things that are going
to get viewers it's like things that
stimulate our basest
human vulnerabilities which are things
that are like fear uncertainty doubt and
as soon as you
and i think like the fragmentation of
media uh what some people like uh this
guy on twitter that i
was talking to daniel addison will say
you know we call it maybe the
fragmentation from our elitist
uh leftist uh perspective he calls it
the democratization of media right that
like
all of a sudden now it's like everybody
has access everyone can be a media
producer
um you know before and actually this is
kind of an interesting potentially like
a historical aberration that like i
think the 20th century was a historical
aberration in that
there was just a couple of centralized
people who controlled the meet like
the main um channels of media and
everybody kind of felt like oh nbc you
know
cbc in canada like all these things had
some
authority um but but before that
actually like i remember being reminded
i forget a friend of mine reminded me or
showed me that actually like before the
20th century media was incredibly
fragmented not to the extent now but
like
there were all kinds of like openly
biased
newspapers uh like you know in the 17th
18th
19th century that were saying like
basically propaganda
for one side or the other and i think in
some ways we're maybe seeing a return to
that but it's obviously magnified by
the online media landscape which is even
more obviously democratized if you want
to use addison or fragmented
if you want to use our perspective but i
don't know maybe
i think that's a really good point i'm
just going to push against one uh
statement that daniel makes right
uh and that's the idea that what we're
seeing right now
can you explain who's daniel your name
yeah he's just someone i was arguing
with on twitter yesterday
is a kind of far-right commentator um
and philosopher right who
is broadly speaking at trump is he an
academic
yes yeah he's he actually teaches like
logic and philosophy at
uh cuny like uh city university of new
york okay
thank you so it's a galleon right but i
mean i've seen that conservatives are
trying to make this argument right that
there's been this democratization of the
media uh away from these big networks
that tend to push
a predominantly centrist liberal point
of view particularly a neoliberal point
of view
and i think there's a certain extent
it's true right but i think that in
a deeper sense this isn't particularly
democratic right uh because
somebody who's sincerely committed to
democracy wants there to be a certain
equality to the kind of voices that are
present in the polity and i don't think
you see that here at all
right i think that you see some voices
being given the cash
and expressed the potential to actually
have a much bigger impact
in the public sphere than others a lot
of these you know people come out of
conservative think tanks are con
are funded by tremendous amount of money
and so i don't think that this is
rightly characterized as a democracy
this is closer to something like a media
poliarchy
uh where there are diffracted media
centers some of which are much more
powerful than others
and have a much bigger reach than others
and what we need is actually a lot more
attention paid to how it is that we can
try to establish a more egalitarian
playing field
when it comes to which views are
expressed and
like so yeah democratization and
fragmentation but how does that
fit in with the the the centralization
of ownership of all of this stuff
because yeah okay but media has been
concentrated in the hands of a few
and even this democratization still
presupposes
social networking websites which are
all also very centrally owned like
somebody owns all the
channels and it's just the content like
the information that flows through those
channels
they do as little as possible to
regulate that except when people force
them to so now twitter is flagging
tweets and
facebook yeah and like facebook's taking
down all these right-wing groups and
hate groups
pages which they really don't want to do
that at all but
with this democratization and
fragmentation comes
actual more ownership of the actual
communication
channels themselves so how does that is
that not
is that not kind of the opposite
movement to dem
because democratization to me would also
imply
the democratization of ownership and as
far as i know
nobody has a stake in this [ __ ] except
for california magnets and other people
like that
i think what we're getting raw are the
the where the boundaries cross
is ownership used to mean
that the person who owns the newspaper
broadcast media television station
whatever
uh there would be pressure from the top
that would
decide what that newspaper or television
station was able to publish
and what they would publish so i think
it's an asymmetry
to compare social media to that because
the
owners of social media presumably
if if they're disinterested and purely
capitalist are
happy no matter what is being posted as
long as more people are reacting
because if people are reacting they're
going to come back if people are coming
back then they're seeing more ads
so in the case of ownership i think
there's an asymmetry between broadcast
media and what we could call
new media and platform ownership versus
like uh mass media ownership
yeah i agree with that i agree with that
i also think i was gonna say we should
make a distinction maybe between
economic democratization than like
democratization of expression or
something like that
and like look i mean i don't i mean i'm
not even the one who wants to push to
say it's become a democratization but
like but if i were to make the argument
i guess i would say like there's been a
democratization of
expression but obviously not a
democratization of economic ownership
of those channels and i would say that
the expression part is meaningless i
mean if you
if we're going to drop mcluhan in here
then the medium is the message
it doesn't matter what the content is
you can democratize what people can say
all you want doesn't matter one bit i
mean that's the ownership
that matters look at zoom zoom came in
and took a huge chunk of the
of the uh video chatting market share
and the other month when they were gonna
have a symposium on palestine
at the university of new york zoom came
in and shut that down
and said this is political this is this
this uh
this uh it goes against our our uh terms
of use i hadn't heard that you can't do
it i haven't heard that
yeah look it up that's a new thing well
that's what they do right it's not that
they
they don't police what you can say they
police what you can't say like there's
certain things that you just can't go on
like israel-palestine no zoom's not
going to have that
like facebook and twitter are the same
they don't really care what you say as
long as it's
within a certain range i guess
i mean like this is the point like
benjamin makes at the end of the article
too like until
real property relations change that's
when the meaningful change happens
because the war machine will mobilize
everybody
and leave property ownership intact
you're next to talk i'm gonna impose a
rule cut this out we're gonna go around
clockwise because we're talking over
each other
like constantly so starting with
strengths
might be arranged differently i'm in the
top right in my
screen oh yeah shame i'm on the really
yeah boomer
you didn't think of that did you in this
hop right also okay why don't we go in
alphabetical order then um starting with
bat
okay yeah no i agree with a lot of
what's been said here right uh i think
you know it's a riff off of uh victor's
points
uh the problem that i have is that what
you see here is
a formal democratization in the sense
that everyone's able to participate but
not
an equality or a democracy of expressive
potential
uh if i want to call it that right uh
and that's because there are some people
whose voices are amplified well beyond
others and
that's a serious problem when you're
talking about the capacity to actually
spread misinformation
or hyper real [ __ ] in today's world
and one example that i can give you is
take a magazine like american greatness
which is a far-right magazine in the
united states that's escalated in
popularity exponentially
uh since trump was elected into office
it's owned by um
private businessmen who funded it to the
tune of several million dollars
and it's able to produce very high
quality very slick uh productions
right uh that propagate a far right
message you compare that with something
like jacket bin right which relies on
you like user donations and typically
for our more small scale
contributions right it's harder for them
to have the same capacity for expressive
potential
that an outlet like american greatness
has even though they've been around for
quite a bit longer and arguably speak
uh to just a significant segment of the
population
right and i think that you're seeing
this become worse and worse in some ways
at least in the united states
uh as a result of a numerous court
decisions like citizenship
united uh sorry citizens united um
and it's a big problem and i'm not sure
what the solution to that is in part
because
every time you try to think of a way to
grapple with this difficulty the
situation changes because new media
emerge
and kind of rethink your entire program
right
i pass because i don't have a response
to that okay uh
yeah i want to say like
i think it's interesting to to like how
we define
um making a difference eric was talking
about like it makes no difference
but also like how we define
democratization i guess like i think the
story is
a bit more complicated than just saying
oh like it makes sense since there's
uh the same owners or centralized
ownership it makes no difference
i mean i guess depends on what you mean
by difference i mean it seems to me that
it's made a huge difference
uh in i mean i think donald trump's
election was was made possible
by like uh you know even in our own
personal lives here right now like we're
making this podcast we have like you
know thousands of listeners or downloads
and like i think that that's only
possible as a consequence of
what some call the democratization of
media
so i mean i don't know it just i i feel
like it's
you know the difference we need to
define what that difference is and i
guess maybe i would ask eric like
when you say like it makes no difference
i mean i guess it makes no difference if
if your goal
like is to democratize to uh
economic ownership then yeah sure it
doesn't make a difference for that but
it seems to make quite a long
large social difference and political
difference in some ways i mean
okay i make a very important point here
and say that backwards viewers are all
attributed to the fact that eric's
sultry voice
just rings out through the podcast every
time i listen to it and
it's irresistible uh so really
almost all of our success should be
attributed to him that's because you can
hear my uvula vibrating
here's i i actually had a specific quote
in mind because i promised i was going
to drop some uh
some uh theory into this and i had
this quote i had in mind comes from
benjamin near the end of his uh
his work of art essay very famous essay
wrote
and the quote goes uh so
let's let's say the forces of fascism
have been on the rise in the states
since trump has been
elected and maybe now they'll peter out
but let's say
here's the quote fascism attempts to
organize the newly proletarianized
masses while leaving intact the property
relations which the
which they the masses strive to abolish
it sees its salvation in granting
expression to the masses
but on no account granting them rights
the masses have a right to change
property relations fascism seeks to give
them expression
in keeping these relations unchanged the
logical
outcome of fascism is an aestheticizing
of political life
and that's the that's the content the
the the content
is left up to the users whatever
but the property relations are all
moving towards fascism they're all
moving towards centralization and
centralized ownership
and that was the point that i had in
mind is benjamin's
idea that you could mobilize your entire
populous in a war and then they all come
back after the war
and property relations remain exactly
where they are no matter how
how victorious you are yeah and i should
actually also add like one of the most
remarkable passages of that same essay
is and i think it's really prescient
when you think about the trump era
and it's that the reason fascism is
appealing in the 20th century is because
fascism is a society deciding to
entertain itself
in the most magnificent possible way
because he says think about fascism it's
very entertaining right
there's always an enemy a heroic story
yeah it's the spectacle violence
you know that's at the center of
everything uh it's extremely
entertaining
uh and that's one of the reasons why
it's so dangerous because it's really
hard to dissociate yourself from
as eric said the spectacle right yeah
it's the aestheticizing means you're
you're making it into a spectacle it's
the immediate
you're aestheticizing politics so people
can say and do whatever they like like
he's writing this
in the 1930s which is again like the
rise of fascism
in europe and germany specifically and i
guess he's he was in france he had to
flee to france by the time he was
writing this maybe
but i mean it's yeah it's very prescient
and it has a lot to do
with today's situation the masses can
express themselves in any way they want
but they have no
right to ownership and that's
that's the problem i got a good segue
here since p is after m
um and i'm going to drop some marshall
mcluhan
uh here's the quote specialist
technologies
detribalize and non-specialist electric
technology
re-tribalizes so in the same way
you have uh like the microphone from a
media studies perspective if you take uh
mcluhan very seriously the microphone
was responsible for nazism because you
can
tribalize on such a broad scale and
people don't have
like the psychological resistances yet
built in
to be able to like place a media within
history
so they become de-historicized
and then can get swept up into something
like nazism and there's problems with
mcluhan and this isn't
like a a proper thesis that i'm going to
sit here and defend but it brings back
this idea of
tribalism that um
when he when mcluhan says that
specialist
technologies de-tribalize he's talking
very specifically about
writing and advanced writing and like i
guess you could say
academic or historical writing whereas
as soon as you have
a mass media then you can also mobilize
a mass using that media so it plays into
this fascism it plays into this
tribalism
and i'm exceeding my time but if i could
finish
then my question is how does this uh
the social media retribalize and i have
a thesis for that
but i'm gonna pass it on too i mean it's
a fascinating question right i mean if
you think that people weren't
psychologically prepared for the
microphone
and it brought all these calamitous
results oh i should have said radio
sorry i meant like radio broadcast sure
sure no but i mean
god only knows how people were possibly
prepared for like the barrage of digital
technologies have been invented over the
last 20 years right
i mean your brain would just not be
prepared for that in any way shape or
form
yeah i mean we're seeing the
impact uh in many different ways i mean
i know
you know it's it's it's it's a different
effect than like the media topic but i
know that like people are talking about
how like young girls
are now like you know much more likely
to cut themselves because i guess like
the bullying online like so there's
something i mean i'm just saying there
is obviously like
a a big impact that we're not
psychologically ready and
you know there's something about the
medium that that um
i think does invite exactly the
tribalization um
yeah i don't know i'll pass it on to
someone else one of the things that i
like about mcluhan that i do actually
think he was pressing
and observing and this is something that
neil postman uh pointed out also in his
book and using our souls of death is
that
uh once upon a time you know print
culture
as it calls in and i think this is kind
of too generic a term uh was ascendant
right uh
and the basic idea of putting it really
simply in his book is that art in his
books
um was that in our gutenbergian universe
the way that people primarily digested
information was through print mediums
uh typically books sometimes long form
newspaper articles
and these all have their problems and
they produce certain kinds of
subjectivities
but they did have the benefit of
encouraging people to deal with
complexity
in a reasonably sophisticated way
because if you're going to read a book
on a topic you're probably going to have
to deal with it in a certain in-depth
sense
since 200 pages is a long
discussion of a topic by any means
especially today right
whereas now with this movement towards a
new acoustic culture
as he puts it where everything tends to
be
short dynamic and to the point
uh people retreat from that kind of
complexity into
antagonisms that simplify the world
and that have kind of virile quality to
them
and part of this is you know due to the
ascendance of
acoustic culture but it's also because
print media uh
books long form articles and all that
kind of stuff has declined precipitously
and one of the things that postman
points out in his book amusing ourselves
to death and you know this is quite
fascinating
uh to me is that uh during the
abolitionist period
um abraham lincoln uh and various
pro-slavery delegates
delegates uh would sit there and have a
debate in front of people
for up to five or six hours at a time
like a five or six hour debate about
slavery yep which it warrants right if
you think about it and all the
complexities involved right
uh and postman says and this is the
1980s who the hell would sit down for
a five-hour debate now you know i mean
within an hour we get bored because
we're used to watching cnn or fox or
whatever it happens to be where these
debates are boiled down to
at that point 20 minutes right and i
think that's even truer now than it was
before right we expect things to be
distilled into
seven minute youtube videos uh and if
it's any longer we think well people are
gonna get bored
uh so we gotta find a way to take this
complicated issue and boil it down to
seven minutes which means you're going
to be very tempted to give a simplistic
scenario
sound bites i mean that's true that
that's
true to some extent but i guess you know
uh to i guess to push against it
slightly like i think we are seeing
uh you know with what some call the the
new democratization of media that there
is actually an appetite for long-form
stuff and like you know i'm not
like i obviously like a group i do
sometimes uh
think that uh there's a tendency in
theory
like theoretical analysis um to to get
to get carried away with like the
narrative of how much worse everything's
getting and like
i agree like there's obviously a lot of
but like that temptation
it can blind us from just like obviously
acknowledging like yeah there are some
things that
are better than they were a little while
ago and like one thing is that this
media does allow
show that there is an appetite for
actually incredibly long form content i
mean some of these podcasts you know
two three hour long i mean discussions
just talking about stuff and people
listen i mean joe rogan
uh you know he's not the the highest
common denominator at all but but he
he does sometimes record podcasts with
like i don't know
per like interesting people for three
people and people listen yeah and uh
so yeah i mean i mean yes the media it's
kind of interesting just how like the
the this new media does kind of
it creates pathways to go both ways
mostly the way that i think we could
complain about and say is is bad and
worse but you know
god also acknowledged the good yeah not
just that i mean you think about like
people like us right like i mean if you
want to learn about a major philosopher
now uh once upon a time you'd have to
actually go to a bookstore buy their
books
read them spend several hours a day
doing it uh now anyone can
put a like pick up their phone put in
their headphones and
listen to some professor give a lecture
on socrates or whatever it happens to be
that's kind of an accomplishment in some
respects right i agree it is kind of
funny you know
not that i'm i'm really not a big fan of
oh god who's that evolutionary
psychologist who's like canadian
he wrote that he wrote that book
recently about how everything's getting
better oh stephen finger stephen pinker
yeah i'm not a fan of stephen finker at
all
but but i did find it amusing like how
how angry people got
like you know on the left like just the
suggestion that things are getting
better
like there is a real resistance to that
resistance to that which i do find kind
of
um amusing even though like yeah like i
said i'm not a fan of pinker
really at all but um
well i think of democratization as well
in terms
of the i mean it's it
it's a new kind of participation so
we're we're seeing
more people participating in the mass
media and we're seeing a close in the
information gap
yeah so people who did not have access
to
any information before now have access
to a whole world of information
and i think the main problem with that
is that there's there's a sort of
learning
curve to this there's there's a there's
an element where
we need to master this new reality
by incorporating it into our we have to
form new habits around it
and right now we have very bad habits
because all of this is happening
so quickly we've barely had a single
generation
to even adapt to this new media reality
where everybody has access
everybody has a voice and one of the
consequences that i'm seeing is that
standards of evidence are going out the
window people are more interested in the
narrative itself
rather than the evidence for that
narrative
evidence has dropped like suddenly
youtube is evidence tick-tock is
evidence
and nobody's critically analyzing the
narrative
in the in the sense that well what's the
evidence that's been
like we can see trump just saying
whatever like they're stealing the
election
there's voting fraud nobody and he's not
presenting any evidence because he
doesn't discuss
youtube because all you do is you you uh
you uh you you opinion shop and then you
pick the opinion that most conforms to
your
worldview you've already formulated and
then you just run with it and [ __ ] it if
anybody thinks differently
because it's your it's your right it's
your god-given right to hold the uh the
views that you do and nobody can change
your mind
all right so it like there's a certain
element what i'm saying
of habituation like even benjamin
pointed this out in his essay like right
we need to master these new media
through habit
not through just sort of they're not
just
and they're not just an addition there's
something new we have to get used to
this is exactly what mcluhan says
because he calls
media the extension of man
but what he's talking about is each of
them are extensions of your body
so being able to listen to us on your
headphones
is just an extension perceptual
apparatus yeah it's an extension
of your ear but the other thing that he
says like i referenced the uh
the hitler radio example before um
but when you you need to form a new
equilibrium
every time a new media technology
disrupts
the environment and i think a lot of
what we're
we're seeing especially with the age gap
right like
the whole q anon thing this kind of
makes sense of it to me
is that if you're grown up if you grow
up in an environment where
you see uh for for whatever reason
the news apparatus as being reliable
when you see something on facebook i
think you're less
not even likely but less able to doubt
the validity of what you're seeing
that's beamed through your eyes
because in the same way that this
podcast is an extension of your ears
the screen is an extension of your
eyeballs and that you can see something
that's telepresent you can see something
that's very far away
so uh one one thing that like just what
you're saying eric is that you might
we might have uh
a psychical slash embodied apparatus
that's actually
incapable of dealing with this
information this much information
at the same time and i think i i don't
know if i would defend this thesis but i
think it does
fall on like age boundaries whether or
not you can trust something that you see
or whether or not you would
trust something that you see can i just
ask a question riffing on this because
this always
struck me as mcluhan's most radical and
honestly i think most unbelievable
thesis and i mean unbelievable in the
pejorable
pejorative sense right uh where he said
like media
are extension of our senses right you
know the telescope is the extension of
our eye
you know the microphone is the extension
of our ear and so on
our headphones are the extension of our
air and so on and so forth
now one of the things that he points out
which i think is actually kind of
interesting
is that there's always been this
presupposition in the western tradition
a natural human being right uh in the
same sense that there's a natural monkey
or a natural deer and so on
uh but one of the things that mcluhan
points out in his mind at least is that
other animals have media as well you
know slugs have shells uh
you know uh do they answer
yeah i know they absolutely have shelves
slugs do slugs
or snails guys when's the last time
you've been outside
slugs don't have shells it's snails
snails oh snails sorry yeah snails have
shells okay my bad
yeah so snails have shells uh and then
you know
monkeys use these rackets and he says
that like thinking of us without media
would be as unusual and abstract as
thinking
of snails without their shells right or
thinking about turtles without their
shells
and i always found this very provocative
and interesting but
because he's trying to denaturalize the
idea that there's some kind of
fundamental human being without our
media
but i'm not really sure how far you can
stretch this metaphor
um um yeah i kind of wanted to also riff
on
something eric said before about like
you know we need to develop new habits
and i think it kind of speaks to what um
pills was saying as well
and i guess this is where i kind of
become maybe a bit of like an anti-uta
or like less utopian and pessimistic you
know it's like
you know i don't really think that
there's ever going to be a time when
like a sick a not insignificant if not
quite significant percentage of the
population
is always going to be incredibly
vulnerable to things like fud right fear
uncertainty doubt like
like i don't think we're gonna reach
some time when citizens
and human beings are like better trained
and can take in information critically
like not gonna [ __ ] happen like
there's always gonna be people who are
because it's easier it's easier to just
to
to be tempted by the simplified story
than it is to
like actually understand what nuance and
critical thinking is
yeah do you know how offended i was the
other day when i saw a cue anon
supporter of all thing
uh saying you know people need to think
for themselves and question everything
and i'm like
oh my god if socrates was here and they
heard you saying that i'm like
you are thinking of yourself and
criticizing everything you're going to
willing to believe
absolutely anything as long as it
coincides with your world view
right exactly you know just being
willing to believe doesn't suddenly make
you a socratic figure
i can reference my my academic days
in saying that um exposure to something
on the internet is
far disproportionately effective
to old people than it is to young people
hmm oh yeah i see my older family
members posting [ __ ]
all the time sharing those chain emails
oh god
critical reading whatsoever just like oh
i saw it it must be real
i'm scared of how much money my omas
donated to the
nigerian prince in exile
[Laughter]
it's funny actually actually literally
just today my like
my one of my favorite undergrad
professors who i'm friends with um
she called me because she got uh
she got some message she clicked on the
wrong thing and she got a message on her
computer that was like
your computer's locked you have to call
us call microsoft and like
unlock your computer and she was like
very unsure and scared and i was like
okay just like
close the browser and then you're her
first call victor
well no no we're we're good friends
we're good friends uh yeah like she
she was actually friends with my dad i
like this example that that benjamin
gives in the article
like you can contrast the new media with
architecture like you think of
architecture as also
media right it's an extension of
ourselves in a certain way
and when we go to work for example we
don't really pay much attention we
receive the architecture
of our workplace and our home and our
local environment in a state of
distraction whereas
things that are new like if you
encounter a brand new building
or new media i mean you encounter those
in a state of like
concentrated awe in a certain way right
you're paying
attention to them when you're walking
through your building right you know
which door is not to open
you know not to fall down a staircase
that's an emergency exit
like you just have all of these sorts of
habitual ways of treating the building
and you know not to walk into a
janitor's closet or something like that
whereas the equivalent
of walking into a janitor's closet on in
new media
is like accidentally dropping into like
a 4chan q and on discussion or something
like that
and then you don't know what to do with
that you're like you're in the janitor's
closet now and you're like oh i guess
this is an important
place because people are discussing it
oh my god
i think that's kind of goes along with
the old people believing these chain
letters and [ __ ] too
i i want to say though i am really
tempted to give like a classically uh
freudian reading
of your interpretation and just say that
like anytime i see a giant building i'm
going to now sit there and think to
myself like
that guy has to have just a monstrously
big penis like
just unbelievably or really small maybe
or both yeah or yeah that you know it's
like one way or another this building
is definitive uh when it comes to
interpreting hispanics actually could i
could i connect some some marilla ponte
to what uh
to what eric just said you know i think
uh i think about what you're saying
there and it reminds me of like you know
the way in our embodied habituation and
like our our kind of like
you know our actual situation as
embodied to be creatures we walk around
and you're right like like you know
uh like things don't solicit you right
like
things that you don't go into i mean
that's one of marilla ponti's like key
terms right it's like with your body is
like habituated
um and changed in in a way that is like
reciprocally engages with the world
where the world will solicit you
based on how like your body's been
habituated right and i think like that's
the difference with new media that like
new media is always
trying to solicit you right like like
it's always pulling you in these
different directions and i think like
and i think uh pills you might be right
that when you're older
like you're really vulnerable to those
solicitations whereas like us you know
we're
we didn't like we like us we grew up
basically with the internet i mean i'm
old enough to remember when it was like
new and kind of like edgy
imagine the generation younger than us
like they really like they're totally
like grew up with it always existing and
always being like a social media like my
students probably undergrads like first
years probably
always had social media in their life
yeah and something shout out to anyone
who remembers
waiting on a browser for a jpeg to
download
and it would be like
[Laughter]
in 2015 there was a child and
she saw an actual physical magazine and
she went out and she tried to touch it
and she was really confused when it
didn't actually like just immediately go
to another screen
but she couldn't understand the concept
of like a paper media have you guys
heard this anecdote of
uh i don't know if it's true or not but
the the kid
who sees a floppy disk and goes why did
somebody 3d print the save icon
that's amazing anyway i can i can't
[ __ ] wait until we get to merlou
ponti because
i think we could stay in merlot ponte
for a long time
um yeah it's useful i think
i i think what's what's really
interesting in the news
or to see news as a mirror world because
the news
does represent things that actually
happen in the world but it's so highly
selective
so as to make the entire world seem
extremely
scandalous like something's always
happening like you have to respond
like your politics matter for example
and it's demanding
a response all the time whereas if you
if you had no access to the news
the world's very boring like even
despite elections
despite who's in power despite uh
like the broad circumstances of the
world the world's a very boring place
and things happen very slowly
almost nothing changes but if you look
at the news
and you don't have like a filter to see
okay this is what is trying to be groped
out of my body from a merlou pontian
sense they're trying to elicit a
response
it creates almost a condition like if
the world were actually like the news
you would be insane to not have anxiety
disorder
it would be like a war it would be like
right yeah it would feel like you know
just
all around just watching you would feel
like you're in nam or something
like my i might it's funny my dad like i
was talking to him the other day and and
he was like you know he doesn't leave
his apartment because he's older and
he's taking medic like medication which
like makes his immune system a little
bit more vulnerable so like he really is
being really careful with kovid stuff
and you know he he sees the news and
he's just watching cable news all day
and he'll
he'll just be like oh like what's it
like in toronto right now like the
numbers and i'm just like i don't like i
don't know like i'm just going about my
business but like
it does create like this this perception
if you if all you're doing is watching
the news
that there's like that the world is
becoming this chaotic thing but it's
true like i mean i think it's worth
noticing how like there isn't really
much of a correspondence between
like what you hear in the news and just
your everyday you know goings on
walking around and it's like i just walk
around and i wear a mask when i go into
stores and like i don't know
i can't see that numbers are higher when
i'm out there in the city like i can't
it doesn't feel like that you know it's
just it only feels like that when you're
watching this this is the thesis of the
spectacle
by the way like the real world would
look much more like
sitting and looking at your backyard for
an entire day
i mean i don't have a backyard and i
probably never will but if i did
that would be what the world looks like
slow changes every once in a while
there's a bird that flies by
and that's it yeah i'll just say like
when i was living in mexico
uh probably because of the media
environment that exists here in
canada and the united states right like
uh people sometimes ask me like are you
safe what's going on
what's happening i'm like it's just a
place like anywhere else you know what i
mean like literally my day consisted of
walking to the store talking to somebody
in spanish being like
a cigarette and him being si senor
uh buying a cigarette going back smoking
it and feeling bad like it's
very very you can buy individual
cigarettes in mexico
you can yeah uh it's basically the
equivalent of three cents
uh for a cigarette that's cheap it is
yeah
dangerously cheap uh but you know the
thing is like if you kind of
get the hyper hyper-real depiction of
this entire society that you see
presented
in uh canadian or american media
it's very different right like it's
drugs and sex and violence constantly
not like that at all it's really quite a
boring place as you would put it uh no
it's full sense
right it's full of it's full of
socialists trying to steal ballots and
burn ballots and create and like
show up with new ballots actually it's
funny because uh i think
if anyone listens to this american life
great uh the recent episode i think is
called like squeaker
uh they like they followed around like a
militia group a white militia group to
like go to polling stations
to basically just like make sure that
there wasn't any funny business
happening
and i think like when you listen to the
story it's describing exactly this right
because
they got all worked up they're like oh
there's gonna be people democrats trying
to steal the election
and they go to the polls and they just
like meet really nice people and they
just like have a nice time and have like
friendly conversations with people and
like nothing's happening
it's like you know but they're expecting
they're expecting to like run in
and have to and like to they were scared
that literally like blm like black lives
matter people were gonna be like
intimidating voters to like vote for
democrats or something and like
obviously yeah you know like captain
woken like the
giant army of blm supporters is just
gonna be like
it's gonna be socialist yeah like you
know we can't allow anybody who looks
even vaguely white to come in here and
cast a ballot
and literally it was just like like
mostly pretty lovely interactions
there's even a really nice one with like
where he starts talking to this
democratic woman and they just have a
very very like friendly
constructive conversation and it's like
nothing's going on
yeah i'd like to redux and say
okay so from another point of view
our news media that we've known from the
past
in the 20th century built on radio
and then television and before that and
newspapers and print media
like today those those institutions i
would say
are failing they're they're failing them
they're failing and that they're fading
away and being absorbed into
other businesses and they're failing in
the sense that they're failing people
too they're not giving proper
information
and also the whole election is another
institution it's a political institution
that's also
failing it is not able to
absorb all of the emotion of the country
in a certain way
so both the news media and politics the
specific institution of elections are
both failing
and they need to be radically
reorganized i just read an article the
other day about
canadian news and how most people don't
realize how
on the brink of collapse canadian media
is
like they are so far gone right now that
they have i mean we probably all know
that the past 10 or 15 years so many
journalists have
gone independent been cut out of there's
big huge
news what do they call them news dead
zones or something places where there's
just a
local newsroom local news is really the
big problem like it's all failing us
and and i know from watching shows like
last week tonight that that local news
reporting does amazing work
they are amazing people and they do
great in-depth journalism and those
things are disappearing because they're
being absorbed again
ownership is changing and they're being
absorbed into larger conglomerates
and they're all changing their focus and
they're becoming kind of homogeneous
so it's kind of strange at the same time
yeah all the media is centralizing like
this but they also don't mind letting
this sort of chaos of everybody's
opinions going on
because it kind of distracts everybody
from that background
like what's really happening in these
spheres that matter everybody's too
focused on the narratives
and what people believe and why they
believe it everyone's too distracted by
all that [ __ ]
which is just a smoke screen for what's
really going on is
centralization standards are failing
people aren't getting the information
they need to go out and vote they're
just being fed all this like
tendentious [ __ ] that has nothing to
do with [ __ ] reality whatsoever
and none of it's backed up by evidence
so to me this is a sign that these
institutions need to be
we don't we can't just let the free
market sort this [ __ ] out because it's
not gonna do it free market
is just like evolution in a cultural
sense it's not gonna work
we need to go in and make a concerted
effort to reorganize these institutions
and make them
work again and they're not going to work
in the same way they work before we need
to figure something
else out we need to make them more
efficient we need to cut away
the administrative and bureaucratic
[ __ ] that's going on
and we need to truly democratize them
and decentralize them and not just
democratize them in the sense that you
can just say whatever you want
because nobody gives a [ __ ] about that
you your voice is immediately drowned
out by the million other voices on there
and the narratives that emerge like the
q and on like the
whatever other conspiracy theories like
voter fraud and all these
all these narratives that emerge they
don't really matter
in the end to me in the long run because
what's happening is a
huge transformation the internet was
just the internet was
just come online in the 1990s
that's like 30 less than 30 years ago
so some something needs to change right
like we can't just use economic
interventions to shore up the old
institutions we don't need
bailouts we don't need bailouts we don't
need
to dump money into these failing
institutions we need to just get rid of
them and change them we need
we need a we need to shift the emphasis
on to back onto local reporting back
onto
higher standards back onto integrity
there's a lot of deontology in that
statement that i don't usually hear from
you eric
you know i'm taking a little risk by
saying like by being a little
prescriptive here
but i think i think compared to what is
happening
like if nobody steps up and say like
this is something we need to do
this is something we need to demand from
our political
and cultural institutions rather than
just letting them sort themselves out
we get boots on the ground and we battle
these narratives one by one like
we're playing [ __ ] whack-a-mole with
psycho right wingers
that's never going to make a big
difference i mean i like the imperative
tense but i've just it's new to me
hearing from you
it also sounds a little vague but like i
agree with the sentiment like i mean
yeah like yeah i mean but like i don't
know what do you suggest like i mean
we're i guess
to some extent we're like lucky in
canada that we have like a public
broadcaster that's significant that
it's like i don't know like how do you
like they i think cbc has uh
local local news in most cities of any
sort of significance
yeah but by the way if you're american
and you haven't heard of state-owned
media
we have some and it's not great it's lib
it's called the
broadcasting corporation but it's better
it's better than our alternatives here
on most issues most of the time so you
know
redistribution socialist broadcasting is
a
is a good place to start well we should
we should we should we may
should we nationalize twitter well less
being less vague about
news organizations i would say we they
need to be public funded so they have
freedom
rather than having to seek private
funding they should be public funded and
then they should also be
strictly separated from like politics
directly in the same way that like
legislative and executive or separate
branches and they
can't the the news needs to also be
publicly funded but also untouchable by
whoever happens to be imprisoned
maybe a good example of that would be
like the model of elections canada
elections canada is like
as an arms-length organization that's
publicly funded and they run all of our
elections in canada right and they write
that and they draw the districts
yeah whereas america leaves it to state
by state
yeah exactly yeah elections canada is a
great example
don't paint to rosie a picture we're
going to get a bunch of immigrants from
the south
[Laughter]
we've got some space out west for you
it's not even that great it's just what
i want is annexation i've been telling
people that it's like if new york state
like new york state to maine and then
like washington state to like california
we're like
we're just [ __ ] tired we want to join
canada i'd be like
100 let's do it well we're gonna let's
take washington oregon and california if
we're going to do that
yeah but i also want new york yeah just
take the big productive centers
we'll have a giant u-shaped country and
upside down to you
exactly and like we can like carve out
like a hole to get
chicago also and just like incorporate
that and then the whole midwest will
just cut them off
yeah something like that you know
our long-term goal here to enact
first of all eric's vision of
state-owned media but then also to annex
the richest states in in the u.s
for canada of course well i remember i
remember i remember for uh humorist
friend leibowitz i remember she's asked
sometimes that her talks you know uh
like how what do you think about the
trump phenomenon like what should we do
differently to like help
to like um you know solve polarization
and she was like you know what it's a
you know there was a civil war here and
i think we made a big mistake
should have just let them leave
[Laughter]
let them separate let them leave let me
let me be clear i don't know about
i don't know if state-owned media is the
same as like a nationalized industry
where everybody sort of has a stake in
it
i think i think that's maybe the way to
go oh like a co-op
or something or well i don't know like
iran for example they have a
nationalized
like oil industry there and it's kind of
like the bane of opec
a lot of the time and it's because
people have
i mean i'm gonna put my foot deep inside
of my mouth if i say this but
but it's it's almost like everyone has a
stake in the industry
so something that's publicly funded that
people also have a stake in
rather than just strictly state-owned
and like some kind of
bolshevik model and not corporate owned
like
the american model somewhere in the
middle but do we allow do we allow
corporate owned uh media to continue to
exist and
i mean public private partnerships like
i've i've
ragged on them a lot and they they're
[ __ ] just on their own but like you
could
throw in a little bit of that maybe i
mean obviously advertising is big money
and you can't just ignore it
like facebook and google snaps up all
the advertising dollars in canada now
because in because when when these uh
companies came out like craigslist
and and and other kinds of listing
websites
immediately the classified section
revenue dried up so you need that sort
of
advertising space and but
right now all the advertising space is
going to google and facebook and other
big media
conglomerates like that and our local
news organizations
and our state owned news organizations
are getting none of it
yeah because also like you know on the
topic of
like like uh centralized corporate
control of things
um you know i've noticed conservatives
complaining a lot about about twitter
and oh yeah since rings hell right
and and and so what's interesting on
twitter about twitter yeah did you guys
hear how they actually like uh how the
number one app right now is something
called parlor
which is like the conservative
alternative to twitter and it's got like
it had like three
three million downloads like last week
after trump was getting censored that's
kind of that's so and like scary but
also
i would i would enjoy it at the same
time because you wouldn't have to see
part of me no you you're gonna get the
beer hall pooch coming out of
some group on there yeah i was
kind of like yeah like good go go over
to parlor i don't know
yeah i mean i was going to say the beer
hall please didn't actually end very
well for those people so you know what
go ahead and try
well that was the first time they were
censored and then you know
i got to commend them because at least
they're actually trying to uh
to use the free market to find an
alternative yeah
and i will say this uh um with eric like
i think one of the bigger problems that
we see right now is
underestimation of the importance of
municipal relations in municipal
government
uh along with local reporting because if
you actually think about it
how your municipality responds to things
is in many ways a lot more consequential
for
people's lives than what the federal
government does either in the united
states or canada and yet
you very rarely ever hear about it right
i mean i know that john tory is
the mayor of this city i could not tell
you who my
councilman is at all i don't even know
what my district is i do know that my
transit works though
if it didn't if it didn't work then i
would probably have to go vote in a
municipal election but yeah like we need
to re-incentivize that kind of local
reporting
and that kind of independent journalism
that we're just not incentivizing it
and it's going away now we're gonna have
a hell of a time getting it back
especially the longer we wait well yeah
and it's interesting because
the american experiment was originally
supposed to be
very like localized it was supposed to
have a very local emphasis that was like
the whole point but then as soon as you
got mass media i think
there is a phenomenon that actually i
think political scientists talk about
where
like local politics became nationalized
in the u.s where like all of a sudden
you were voting for
like your local congressman based on
whereas like before
like and which was for the majority of
the united states existence
like local politics and who your local
member was
you'd often split your vote and you'd
vote maybe like for a democrat locally
but a republican nationally and there's
that was much more common just because
people were
much much more connected um to what was
happening and what their local interests
were
and state interests versus their federal
interests
and that that certainly i think media
the growth of new media and just like
you know 20th century media did see a
steep decline in what was
yeah like i said america was originally
supposed to be a bunch of local like a
bunch of states
like very localized you know um but that
that's kind of totally gone away
yeah and the fact that you can even
point to a silent majority
is kind of an indication that there's
not enough local channels
for people to learn and people to
express their opinions about things
or at least people to channel their
energy
while we wrap up here i just want to
recall
one more quotation or our concept
quotation from
the sage of toronto marshall mcluhan
who said that i thought you were going
to say jordan peterson i thought you
were going to say doug 4.
no the sage of toronto is a proper
term designated for marshall mcluhan
even deborah called him that but he said
uh the secondary orality that we're
entering
through telepresence or presence over
you know what the internet now um
will bring us into a new global village
and he saw this as kind of a good thing
but the board's criticism of this and
this is excellent the board said
what what mcluhan never understood is
that
we're going to bring back a global
village but what happens in a village
it's
gossip backbiting uh
rumors spread very quickly and all of
these negative aspects to being in a
village that
uh mcluhan never brought up because he
was so hyped on this idea of
an oral connection between people so
with that i think uh
we're ready to sh what an excellent
quote i couldn't agree more i mean
i hate village life it's the worst
um so with that uh this is a little bit
of a different episode how do you guys
think
it went well where i thought that was
pretty good i don't know it was fun yeah
i mean like it's nice not to have to
talk about things like an academic
every now and then but i feel like we
were pretty good about bringing up
some academic concepts here and there
like i don't know i feel like this i
feel like this was good
i was able to refer to like freudian
theories of buildings as penises so i'm
very content
well i know that's you know this pasta
felt like i was at the bar
it's like a conversation we'd have at
the at the bar i i ate some pasta and
drank some beer and
all right if we have feel like there's
three categories of episodes
on this uh what do you call it channel
podcast
we have the interviews then we have the
deep dives and these are going to be the
topical episodes
which i think all of us tend to enjoy
more because
we're not trying to flex or do
research which nobody likes to do
shooting the [ __ ] i like research [ __ ]
all y'all
no this was this was fun i think and
hopefully it'll come out sounding pretty
good we'll see
yeah i'm gonna have to cut cut up some
of the name dropping about
terms that our international audience
and thank you international audience
but they're not going to understand what
they are so um that all said
thanks you guys a lot for showing up uh
i have a
an appointment to meet even in this hour
of night what's the appointment
we're still working on
i'm forming the global village okay
all right guys thanks we'll see you
later thanks everybody
yep all right
[Music]